So, I really hope this was a useful introduction to Unreal Engine animation states and controlling
animation inside of Unreal Engine and just the different opportunities you have, whether
you want to author animations outside of Unreal Engine and bring them in via the FBX importer.
Do you want to do a lot of the animation driven sequences inside of Unreal and really get
the most out of working in real time within your scenes and using the different tools
such as Control Rig to then manipulate the content to create the best output. Or maybe
you want a blend of the two and hopefully there's a lot of tools here for you to just
play around with, especially loading up the sequences and the blueprints just to get a
feel for how you interface the information and how the flow of information works. So,
I hope you found this useful and thank you for watching.